an Ohio grandmother is nearly halfway
through a road trip to visit every
National Park in the United States joy
Ryan known as grandma joy his 89 years
young until four years ago she had never
seen a mountain or an ocean
chip Reid met grandma joy and the
grandson taking her on the cross-country
Joyride at Virginia's Shenandoah
National Park on the road again in
Virginia's Shenandoah National Park this
week Brad Ryan and his grandmother Jory
admire the spectacular view of the
valley far below it's one of 29 national
parks the two have visited over the past
four years from the redwood forests of
California to the Gulf Stream waters of
Florida their goal is to visit all 61
national parks the extraordinary journey
began after joy than 85 told Brad she
regretted that she'd never seen an ocean
or a mountain
I never climbed one but he fixed that so
you climbed a mountain once you don't
have a burning desire to climb another
mouth no I think that'll be sufficient
but they didn't stop there two years
later they set out on a 28-day camping
trip we stayed in a tent every night and
we had our routine down the moment that
we pulled into the campsite she's
assembling the tent stakes bread says
he's always known his grandmother had an
adventurous spirit but she continuously
surprises him to see your grandmother
not just walk across the Great Sand
Dunes National Park but then rolled down
one Brad created an Instagram account
share photos of the trip recently their
journey went viral worldwide and grandma
Joyce named got lost in translation
some countries have now misconstrued her
first name and they've been calling her
grandma pleasure which is uncomfortable
I think it's mortifying life has not
always been so beautiful for joy she was
widowed 25 years ago and had to work a
low-wage job until she was nearly eighty
two of her three sons died in middle age
a lot of people move through their
tragedy with a darkness about them and
she has never shown that someone asked
me why do you smile all the time lies
there would you rather at me an old
grump Brad and joy have received
messages from people all over the world
inspired by their journey those who tell
them I'm not gonna waste another day and
I'm going to make sure that I do this
with my grandmother sometime that could
also apply to a mother or a father or a
grandfather off anybody he loved there's
a lot of love here yep I wouldn't trade
him for nothing
me neither grandma thank you I love you
too bad
love the fuel that powers this epic
journey for CBS this morning
chip Reid Shenandoah National Park
[Music]